el grupo interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes el Hi presentó su tercer
informe sobre el caso Ayotzinapa en
torno de la desaparición de 43
estudiantes en Guerrero en conferencia
de prensa para dar a conocer sus
hallazgos determinaron que hay una
injerencia indebida de instancias
Superiores de la fiscalía general de la
república sobre la unidad especial de
investigación y litigación del caso
Ayotzinapa que busca obstaculizar la
labor del fiscal especial Omar Gómez
Trejo que incluso llevó a este a
presentar su renuncia en días recientes
dijeron que el fiscal Gómez Trejo se ha
desempeñado con total rectitud y
profesionalismo y que su renuncia y la
intromisión pone en riesgo toda la
investigación por otra parte tras haber
tenido acceso a archivos de la defensa
nacional esto tras la autorización del
presidente López Obrador el higié
concluyó que el ejército tiene un centro
de inteligencia militar desde Iguala
desde donde operó todo un seguimiento
monitoreo constante de todas las
actividades de los estudiantes desde el
20 de septiembre de 2014 hasta fecha
posterior a su desaparición incluso
concluyeron que había algunos
estudiantes con vida hasta el 4 de
octubre toda esta intervención de
telecomunicaciones se llevó a cabo con
el sistema de espionaje pegasus y
también intervinieron teléfonos de
criminales de Guerreros Unidos y
establecieron que hay una total
complicidad de este grupo criminal con
todas las autoridades de distintos
niveles desde municipales hasta fuerzas
federales y fuerzas armadas
confirmaron también la existencia de un
quinto autobús involucrado en la noche
de Iguala que habría ido cargado de
droga lo cual tiene que seguir siendo
investigado reconocieron como avances la
creación de esta unidad especial y
también de la comisión para la verdad y
el acceso a la justicia pero
recomendaron al presidente López Obrador
mayor acercamiento y diálogo con los
padres de los estudiantes